This is the opening scene of season two of
Broad City. Abbi and llana, the show’s creators
and best friend protagonists are just trying
to survive a chaotic subway ride.
“Val? Val!”
And the camera kinda lands on these other
two women who are standing there with pepper
sprayed eyes.
That's Caroline Framke
I write about culture at Vox. I’ve watched
and analyzed this show to death.
Like many of the best moments in Broad City,
the entire scene is super surreal, so the
two women probably wouldn’t stand out to
a first time viewer.
But, if you watch Broad City religiously like
we do, you’ll immediately get the joke.
Those two women are a callback to a moment
in the first season when Abbi and Ilana actually
got pepper sprayed. They’re wearing the
same clothes and have the same devastated
looking faces. Ilana’s doppelganger is even
holding the same curtain rod.
That’s a callback.
Your typical joke in a TV comedy requires
very little space between the setup. Take
the classic Dick Van Dyke Show
Rob: “Honey will you grab me a handkerchief?”
Laura: “We’re only going next door!”
[ VOX CITY LOGO ]
Your typical joke in a TV comedy requires
very little space between the setup.
[CLIP] Dick Van Dyke Show:
Rob: “Honey will you grab me a handkerchief?”
Laura: “We’re only going next door!”
and the punchline.
Rob: “Well I guess I’ll run back here
to blow my nose.”
If you’ve never seen the show before you’re
still guaranteed a good laugh.
[Audience laughter]
But there’s another set of much more intricate
jokes that are written specifically for diehard
viewers.
They are callbacks, running gags, and easter
eggs.
So, what’s a callback exactly?
A callback references a moment or joke that
most likely happened in a previous episode.
Seinfeld was one of the first shows to employ
callbacks pretty regularly.
To use two famous Seinfeld episodes. One to
set it up is “The Contest” Where all the
characters compete to see who could go the
longest without masturbating.
“So you’re still master of your domain?”
“Yes yes I am.”
Caroline: George wins. Then later in the “Puffy
Shirt” episode -
That’s Season 5
George is trying to be a hand model.
A client makes a reference to a previous client
being "Master of his domain."
Client: "He was not master of his domain."
And George says not to worry about it
George "You don't have to worry about me.
I won a contest."
If you’re a casual viewer you’re not gonna
know what that means.
But if you’re a viewer that’s stuck with
Seinfeld a little bit you know exactly what
that means.
Callbacks can very easily turn into running
gags if they keep happening again and again.
Like, no one knows what a chicken sounds like
on Arrested Development.
That is not how a chicken sounds. Chickens
don't CLAP!
coo ca coo coo ca coo
chi cha chi cha chi cha
Awe this is priceless. Coo ca coo
A coo da doodle doo a coo da doodle doo
You're a chicken! coo coo ca chaaw coo coo
ca chaw!
You're the chicken, not me. Clock clock clock
clock claaaawwwww
Or how Kenneth the page is an immortal flesh
vessel in 30 Rock.
Kenneth: I've worn this old jacket since 19
hub a dah
You killed the bird I had for almost 60 years.
Sure I was legally dead for 5 minutes
Who said I've been alive forever?
Because when I look into a mirror there's
just a white haze.
And in Broad City?
Abbi always having to clean increasingly gross
things out of the gyms bathroom.
Trey: Got something for ya.
Abbi: Oh okay
Trey: Big ol clogged toilet in the women's
room.
Trey: We got another pube situation in the
women's locker room
Trey: We could really use some Abbi magic
there's a pube situation in the locker room
that is unprecedented.
Trey: Somebody barfed on an excercise ball
and then in bounced down 2 flights of stairs.
So.
Trey: There's a bloody shit spew in the spin
studio. But really there's a bloddy shit spill
in the spin studio.
A good example of how intertwined callbacks
and running jokes can get is a stylistic choice
that Broad City has made for a couple of moments.
When Abbi and Ilana are thrown off or disoriented
by a piece of news.
Morgan: “Oh my God, she doesn’t know?”
Ilana: “Know what?”
And it’s because Ilana finds out that Abbi
made out with a friend of theirs.
Morgan: “Darcy and Abbi made out!”
Ilana has always wanted to make out with Abbi
and has never gotten to, so this is a very
personal blow to her.
This is a direct callback, shot for shot,
to a moment when Abbi misses a package delivery
that’s she’s supposed get for her neighbor
/ crush, Jeremy.
At this point? That’s a callback. If they
use it again and keep using it, that can become
a running joke.
One of my favorite callbacks in Broad City
actually begins in “Working Girls” when
Abbi has to track down Jeremy’s lost package.
Operator: "Your borough's distribution center
is on North Brother Island.
Abbi: "Is that in New York? I've never even
heard of that."
Operator: "Yeah it's in the East River"
Here we're introduced to Garol.
Abbi: "Hello, Garol. I'm not sure I'm in the
right place."
Garol:" You are."
Garol was the keeper of lost packages.
In other words an old lady eating yogurt alone
in a warehouse on North Brother Island.
You would think Garol is just an amazingly
cast one hit wonder, but fast forward 12 episodes
and she’s the patron of a speakeasy that
Abbi performs at when she’s blackout drunk.
Abbi performing as this sort of Liza Minelli-ish
lounge singer with this very exaggerated accent
is so wonderful because if you are a diehard
Broad City fan you might remember what we’ll
call an easter egg.
Abbi: Val about town. Town about Val.
Crowd: Hey Val! Val!
Ilana: “How did I not know that when Abbi
gets blackout drunk she becomes Val?”
Wait, Val? Let’s rewind back to the 2nd
season premiere.
“Val? Val!”
The best part about this entire moment is
how Abbi is just as confused as we are. At
that point we’d never heard of Val before.
It's a very elaborate set up.
It's an amazing easter egg.
Almost every viewer will get a running gag.
More attentive viewers will get callbacks.
Only diehards will get easter eggs.
If a TV show can pull off Callbacks, running
gags, and easter eggs it can really build
out a much more satisfying world.